[intense music playing]
Cameras aren't working and
it's getting super frustrating.
CHRIS MULTOP: This is what
it's like on "Life Below Zero."
Cameras already down.
Tough conditions all
around to film in.
WOMAN: No heat, no
power, no anything.
[grunts] Won't even turn on.
WOMAN: I've fallen
too many times.
We have bad winds and it's just
a typical day in the Arctic.
MAN: Making the best
of what we've got.
[intense music playing]
It's really cold, but
this is kind of our job.
This is what we do.
This is what we live for.
How can we do that
out-of-the-box cinematography?
MAN: The Iditarod is
something I've been dreaming
about doing for 12 years.
And it's the last great race.
This is the grand
Olympics of the north.
First thing I'm going to
have to do is get out my maps
and get out my mileages, and
start making a race plan.
More people have summitted
Everest than have finished
the Iditarod in 47 years.
Jesse is planning out his
Iditarod, all the stuff he has
to take for the Iditarod race.
It'd be really cool to get a
cool specialty shot time lapse,
but we're trying to
figure out how to do it.
And Benji had a good idea.
He's like, what if we
did this corkscrew,
bird's eye view
over his shoulder?
BENJI LANPHER: I haven't
seen it done on the show yet,
and this was kind of exciting
about it-- is that it's
something kind of
new and we're trying
to push it a little
bit as far as in terms
of making this kind of pop.
CHRIS MULTOP: But
we're just going
to make do with what we've
got, and start building,
and see if it'll work.
The part that sucks, because
it's cold and my hands
are going to get cold.
Ha!
[clattering]
Man, that burns.
I know one of the things that
we really strive for on the show
is, outside of a great story,
is to try to do these incredibly
creative shots that are
out of the box usually
utilizing stuff that's not meant
to be used that sort of way.
So every trip, every show,
every episode that we produce,
we do that out-of-the-box
cinematography.
[drilling]
This is all we've
got to work with.
It's not like you just
go get any ol' bolt
and size you need at the
hardware store, you know?
Oh, perfect.
All right, let's
go take it up there
and see if we could hang it.
[dogs barking]
All right.
So far, so good.
BENJI LANPHER: The
idea of the shot
is to pull out from the map,
so you can see him writing
and then pull out and twist.
You'll see it but we're going
to try to keep the map in focus
the entire time as we pull out.
The lens is cold, so what
we have to do every time
we bring any of our
gear, cameras or lenses,
from inside to outside is
we have to let it acclimate.
So it gets foggy out here
and then it gets foggy
on the inside.
We can't shoot until
this lens acclimates
to the temperature inside.
The idea is to really
show that essence
of time passage for all
the work that he has to do.
We want to do the
most incredible
shot that we can try to pull
off to make that look amazing.
Half the battle in these
time lapses is the ingenuity,
and being innovative,
and creative.
WOMAN: Running the loader,
and this is what I noticed.
This is oil that's
being blown up.
This is the piece
of machinery that's
going to get my runway fixed.
This has got to get fixed.
Once it does, I'm
back in business.
But until it is,
I'm out of business.
MIKE CHEESEMAN: And we're
going to try to capture
the whole time lapse
all the way across Kavik
with dusk all the way into the
night to the northern lights.
And we need a lot of weight,
because we're going to put
a lot of tension on the cords.
So we're going to
ratchet-strap one point in,
ratchet as hard as we can down,
and then we're going to run
the line all the way across.
The more tension the
better, because we
don't want the camera to sag.
We want it to be taut.
There we go.
As you can see, one
point is secure.
It's not going one
way or the other.
We're going to put a
lot of tension on this,
so we need to make sure
it's pretty stable.
So here's our
beginning of the shot.
We'll be here.
We're trying to achieve a
full Kavik from her storage
shed, generator shack,
loader all the way
to the front of the Twinkie.
So from 80 paces,
roughly 80 feet,
we'll be able to go
the length of her camp
all the way to the front.
So we're probably about
60% done with the tension.
And as we're
pulling the tension,
the barrels are moving.
So now we have to figure out
more weight for the barrel.
So when we put more tension
on, the 100% tension,
we will be solid and
the barrels won't move.
The ropes are perfectly even.
The carriage will ride
straight, and it won't bounce
off the wires or the rope.
So we're pretty
much at that point
where we can mount the 5D.
The temperatures aren't
in the negatives yet,
but our motor for the slingshot
time lapse is all metal.
I need to just
basically insulate it,
and an easy way to do it is
just to use an extra beanie.
And that at least insulates
it enough that it stays warm.
Houston Texans save the day.
So we just set it.
The camera is now rolling,
and the best thing we can do
is get the hell out of the way
and let the camera do its work.
[music playing]